COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some leaping
lizards track down
why their bandwidth
was off in the weeds.
Will we catch
what's bugging them?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I got a nice call from the Gecko
Protocol team, a B2B company
offering a custom, lightweight
networking protocol, built
for gaming and other
real-time graphics systems.
Their team was seeing lower
than expected throughput
for their back-end
machines, which
are responsible for
transferring and transcoding
large video and graphics files.
Their architecture worked a
little something like this.
A client will push about
two terabytes of data
to cloud storage.
At the same time, it
kicks off work request
to a front end, which leverages
a TCP load balancer to spin up
a bunch of compute and engine
instances in a single region
to feed on that data,
talk between each other,
and get the work done.
Most of this was
working as expected.
However, the Gecko
Protocol group
was concerned about VM
to VM throughput, where
they were only seeing about
1.5 gigabit per second max
connections.
I duplicated their
setup on my side,
which involved a bunch
of one-CPU machines
in a single region
and ran iPerf on them.
The result was
about 1.95 gigabits
per second, which was
much higher than what
Gecko Protocol was seeing.
Now, I knew from experience
that for high bandwidth systems,
they were obviously
using too small a machine
for those efforts, since
networking throughput
is related to core count.
Bumping it up to about 16 CPU
machines in the US central one
region, I was able to
get about 15.9 gigabits
per second--
obviously, much better.
However, when the Gecko
Protocol team switched over
to this configuration, they
didn't see the same results.
They only ended up at about
1.6 gigabits per second.
After about 20 minutes
of a video chat trying
to get our
configurations identical,
the solution smacked
us right in the face.
The problem was that their
team was testing the connection
to the external
IP of the server,
while I was testing
on the internal IP.
See, if two machines
are communicating
using their internal
IPs, then they
can send traffic on
Google's private internet,
which is super fast.
Using the public IP, however,
forces the data packet
to get pushed to
the public internet
before coming back to
the machine, a.k.a.
not the fastest.
When we switched over
their configuration
to use the internal IPs with
the larger machine setup,
the bandwidth went
through the roof--
15.9 gigabits per second.
For Gecko Protocol, this
small debugging session
resulted in their
video and graphics data
transfer rate
improving by about 14x.
For more great Cloud content,
subscribe to the Google Cloud
YouTube channel,
and stay up to date
with other Cloud Performance
Atlas video content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]